(contemplative music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our guest today is George Packer who is
a staff writer for The New
Yorker, the author of many books,
most recently The Unwinding which won
the National Book Award for nonfiction.
He is on the Berkeley campus
as the 2017 Jefferson lecturer.
George welcome back to our program.
- Good to be with you again Harry.
- Last time you were here we
talked about The Unwinding
and when I asked you what you learned
from doing that research and writing
that book about where America was.
- That book has been cited
as a primer on Trump's
America, Trump's victory.
I think I have to reject that a little.
I didn't imagine Donald
Trump's presidency.
I believed the polls last year.
I thought he would win because the poll,
I mean I thought Hillary would win
because the polls said she would.
But the book did survey a landscape
that was preparing the way for Trump.
So Trumpism, the feelings the impulses
that we call populism that
fueled the support that drove him
to victory in the Republican Primary,
the victory in the General Election
was all there in the
places I was reporting on
five, six, seven years earlier.
So I wasn't, I was I guess
shocked but not surprised
by his victory because
that work had prepared me
for something like that
I just didn't think
we were quite that far gone.
- And what were the some of
the things that you found?
I mean you were going to
different parts of the country
talking to different people
of different social class
and there were some common themes.
I mean as people responded
to the 2008 crash.
Yeah that was the context
for my reporting was
the financial crisis
and the Great Recession.
The early Obama years.
I was in western North Carolina,
rural tobacco and textile area.
I was in exurban Tampa Bay where
the housing bust was most dramatic
and there were all these new subdivisions
that were practically deserted.
I was in Youngstown, Ohio
which is classic Rust Belt City
and it it kind of didn't matter whether
I was talking to a
Democrat or a Republican,
to someone in a city or a small town,
to someone who was black or white.
There was a common sense
of the game that they play
being rigged in favor of
people who had the connections,
who were in the right networks,
who had power and money
of the middle class disappearing,
of their children's chances being poor.
And of this globalization
kind of sweeping away
the life that they knew
whether it was the factory
or the shops in this small
town Main Street or what.
So there was just a general
feeling of anxiety and
suspicion, suspicion of each other too.
I kept running into people
who thought something,
someone was scamming them
or something was a scam.
And also the the way they got information
was no longer through one of three or four
respected establishment news sources.
It was their own tailored
information world that they could choose.
So it was either Fox, or MSNBC,
or their favorite websites.
Twitter had not yet become quite
the deafening echo chamber it is now but
Facebook was beginning to
become a major source of news so
I would say if you want to
look at three factors in
the rise of Trump they were all there.
One was economic stagnation
and a sense of falling behind
and growing inequality
that's been true for decades.
The change in the color and culture of
towns that had not had immigration before
that were beginning to feel the effects
of several decades of
open immigration policies.
And three social media and new media that
made it possible for people to get around
the established voices and instead
to hear more radical voices and to
choose whether or not to believe them.
And often they did
because the radical voices
spoke more directly to them.
- And there was a sense in
your book of kind of the
general collapse of institutions
that might support people.
And when you're talking
about the democratic
institutions a real lack of trust.
- Yes, certainly the Federal
Government felt like a
dysfunctional and
parasitic and far off thing
that had nothing to do with them
in any sort of supportive way.
And even to some extent State Government.
But also think about churches.
Even though I was in very
religious parts of the country
the church didn't play
the kind of cohesive role
in the lives of people I was with.
And these are very anecdotal
and idiosyncratic stories.
I wasn't looking for
statistical representation.
There were really no unions to speak of.
The woman I wrote about in
Youngstown had been in a union
when she worked on an assembly line
but her job had gone off to Mexico.
And the union had had dissolved
with the end of that factory.
And civic groups were not in their lives
and corporations were just
giant bodies that use their
labor when they needed it
and offered them no security in return.
And there was a family in
Tampa whose husband was
always working odd hours at the Target,
the local Target stockroom
but they would call him
when they needed him and
sometimes he had too few hours
in a week to support his family.
So seemed to all be at the
convenience of the corporation.
These are the institutions that
in this the great post war boom
were the heart of the of the middle class.
The institutions that
were like the foundation
on which a middle class
life could be built.
They weren't there and then the media
the last one had become kind of a weapon
more than a source of stability.
A weapon in the political wars that
Americans are now all engaged in.
- Your intellectual
odyssey is one coming from
a very liberal background,
maybe at times a radical background
in terms of your own experiences were.
Were the people you talking
to did they have a sense
of the class that they belonged to,
the traditional importance of unions,
what had been the bread
and butter of liberal
radical constituencies in the past?
- For the woman in Youngstown Tammy Thomas
the union was a fact of life and it was
like the local school, it was just part of
the fabric of her life but
it wasn't in her corner.
It didn't fight for
her in her in her view.
And when the job started to go,
and then when the buyouts
started to happen.
When the factory closed
the union was helpless
and it didn't put up
much of a fight at all.
This family in Tampa it was interesting.
One night we were talking
and the husband said
he had just seen a documentary
on the History Channel
about a strike in West
Virginia in the 20's,
a famous violent coal miners strike
at a place that's famous but I can't
remember the name unfortunately.
And he was telling me that
at Target they showed them
the employees videos, propaganda videos
about why unions were bad for them.
And why if there was
ever a vote for a union
they should vote against it.
And it wasn't as though he felt
how dare the company
try to cheat me out of
my right to have, to be organized.
What he said was I
watched that documentary
I couldn't figure out what
was so bad about them.
It's like it was some
distant thing that he
knew existed once in the past decades ago
and had stopped existing and was now
part of the History Channel.
But it seemed like not such a bad thing
so why was Target telling
him it was such a bad thing.
So that made me sad because
it showed how far away
that tradition had gotten from a true
working class American in Tampa.
Which was a union town by the way.
- The transition from the
time of your research, writing
to the emergence of the era of Trump
has been one in which,
and you point this out
in your October 2016
article in The New Yorker
on the campaign, one in which
identity politics emerged.
I guess the question I
had was that apparent
at the time of your writing or
when does this transition
become so powerful?
It's really an important
feature of the campaign.
- I think identity
politics is always with us
and a self conscious
white identity politics,
not just white domination
but white identity politics
to me first emerged in the
candidacy of Sarah Palin
when she flaunted kind of
small town white culture,
white boots, white
music, redneck woman was
the theme song of her campaign.
It was in your face identity politics
and her crowds were entirely
white which isn't always true
even at a Republican political event.
And that was when I
first noticed this thing
that had emerged which seemed
offensive and resentful
and like about kind of demanding
our rights which is not,
in general white politics is
simply the dominant politics.
It's not self conscious in that way
but it seemed to be taking
on some of the forms of
non white identity politics
when she came along.
But then it got submerged for a while.
Good old fashioned racism was there
in many places I was writing about
especially in North Carolina where Obama
was deeply unpopular with most people,
although not with the the
guy I was writing about,
Dean Price who sort of revered
and was obsessed with Obama.
So it was clear that Obama
as the first black president
was an affront to a lot of people I met
in the small towns of
Western North Carolina,
Southern Virginia, Martinsville area.
I remember in the
midterm elections of 2010
being at a polling place
in Martinsville and
an older white woman whose
husband had just recently died
just spitting angry at Obama for
being in the Oval Office and for somehow
running down the presidency
and not speaking right,
not dressing right, and all these things
I found just mind boggling.
What are you talking about?
She thought this man is somehow
desecrating the presidency.
I mean wonder how she feels about
the guy who's desecrating
the presidency right now.
That was there but the
reaction to Obama on the left
and among minorities
took a few more years and
that came after my book was published.
The following year, 2014 with Ferguson
and Black Lives Matter,
and the other incidents
of police brutality and it changed
the atmosphere dramatically.
The last two years of Obama's
presidency were characterized,
the dominant political
event in the country was
the return of identity
politics on the left.
And that's still with us today.
And it's now I think at
even more intense level
because Trump is producing a reaction.
- Before we talk about identity politics
I do want to have you
repeat the phrase you have
about Sarah Palin's relation to Trump.
You recall a beautiful phrase.
You call her the...
- John the Baptist--
- For Trump.
- She was the the one who went before
and was a harbinger of what was to come.
And she was one of his first supporters.
She was poor and he was rich.
But they were breathing
the same noxious air of
celebrity worship and kind
of lowering of standards,
celebrating the lowering of standards.
I was sitting in a diner in a little town
in Southeastern Ohio in the fall of 2008.
She had just been nominated Vice President
and these women were
saying to me we love her.
I said why and they said
she would fit right in here.
She's just like us.
And that too was kind
of a epiphany for me.
You mean what you want is
you in the highest office,
not someone with
qualifications, experience
who speaks in a slightly different way
and who knows their way around
foreign capitals, et cetera.
You want you.
That was a sign of utter
cynicism toward the political class,
contempt for expertise, and populism.
That's what populism sounded like.
And that was when I
really began to hear it
with Sarah, with John
the Baptist Sarah Palin.
- One of the themes in
earlier works is this
coming to terms with
your observations that
reason was being displaced basically
as part of the discourse basically.
And we're moving not your,
this is an observation
on your point that that
rational discussion
was leaving the public space and
what you just described is a sense of
there's an emotional reaction to her.
It's not thought out.
It's not the result of the policies
that Sarah Palin is proposing.
- You know I think we
have to be careful not to
imagine a past that
was better than it was.
I think politics is almost always
dominated by people's emotions.
Choices of leader are
dominated by how you feel
about someone which might be
even pre-verbal or nonverbal.
But in the debates that I
grew up watching for president
the policies were the kind of the heart
of what they were arguing about?
What you might remember
is there you go again
or where's the beef
but that had to do with
what you're gonna do to
Medicare or Social Security.
- You're talking about an earlier period.
Not in in the recent period.
- I'm talking about like the 70's, 80's.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Now
do candidates even
approach a debate thinking
I've got to win the policy debate?
Or do they think I've
got to appear to be like
this kind of person in order to connect
with a segment of the population
that wants that kind of person?
I think Trump's campaign
although he had slogans
and even kind of half baked policy ideas
that appeal to people what really
provided the energy was the character
and the kind of language he used.
This is not new.
I don't want to say that in the past
we've all been Oxford
Debate Union citizens
who just decided you scored
more points than you.
Of course not.
But it feels like this
is now displaced any
almost anything else this is
where politics has gotten.
And that's also populism because
it means establishing a direct connection
between the leader and the people
which Trump consciously did.
I am your voice.
I alone can fix it.
That was his way of saying
I'm channeling my followers.
And so they identify with him personally.
And they were the same hat and
that makes it very difficult
to persuade people of things
because it's a tribalism,
it's a tribal identity.
- An important piece of
your Unwinding book was
a whole section on the celebrity culture.
And although Trump isn't one
of the figures you identified--
- He almost was, damn it.
I thought about, I
thought he's too obvious.
If I put him in people will just say
oh I think of course Trump is in there.
- That that was because
you lived in New York
and we're so used to him basically.
But it in other words
when you think about that
section of your book you
and then you look at Trump
oh yeah this is I mean
so there is this element of him
that you capture in the profiles where you
seem to be saying that
leaders are people we admire
because the great life they live.
- They live it in in our stead.
We don't aspire to being where they are.
That's for an age of upward mobility.
They represent us, they speak for us.
And I saw that in
sort of in Sam Walton's
story which is the story
of a small town guy from Missouri
who becomes the world's richest man.
And in some ways they don't
have to be because he's
like them he's a figure
that they can identify with.
Jay-Z, I had all these
celebrity profiles so
from different sectors of our society.
From politics, from entertainment,
from business, finance, government.
Jay-Z at a concert that I went to
so that I had some feel for
him was saying to his fans
I am the new Jackie Robinson.
I'm breaking all the barriers.
I'm a part owner of the Brooklyn Nets.
We're in the Barclays Arena
which I'm a part owner of.
I am you in this place,
I'm at the table for you.
And the fans would
flash his corporate logo
back at him to say yes we
follow you, we have your symbol.
And that seemed like a new
way to relate to celebrities.
When I was growing up
celebrities were sports heroes
could draw a great deal of admiration
but they were kind of like a diversion.
Liz Taylor and Richard
Burton are at it again.
But now they're like a brand
that you associate with
and it's a way of feeling
as if you have a place
in the sun when you know you won't
because the doors don't
open for you anymore.
And I think of it as a kind of malign
symptom of loss of
faith in our own ability
to govern ourselves instead
we hand it off to these god's.
- In The New Yorker article you make
an important distinction
going back to this problem
of identity and the working class
in which what emerged for the first time
either during the campaign or before it
was the notion of a white working class.
So identity politics was
combined with traditional notions
of thinking about society
in terms of class.
Talk about that.
- There's always been a
very clearly identified
white working class and
it's had different names.
Blue collar was its name 50, 70 years ago.
Tradesmen, working man,
in the 19th century.
It's now a kind of
political science category
because it behaves in a
particular way that is distinct
from other groups of whites.
It gave Donald Trump his victory.
I mean it was overwhelmingly the force
that brought him to office.
- [Harry] He won every category.
- He won every category
of white but his vote
among working class whites which
I think the political scientists define
as non-college degree was overwhelming.
In some areas it was like 75% which
was not true for Mitt Romney in fact
Obama won some of those
votes in 2008 and 2012.
So something shifted and I
think it's this identification
with Trump as their
voice as their tribune.
Not his policies but
his character his ethos
and it's a, I think a probably
inevitable response to
two terms of a black president which
for some white Americans was a
shock and an unwelcome shock,
and becoming another
minority group among several
rather than the dominant majority.
As we become a more ethnically
heterogeneous society
with immigration and
with demographic trends
whites who feel like the deck is stacked
increasingly stacked against them
are going to see themselves
as a group with a grievance.
And that became Trump's group so
the white working class
which has always been
a big category for political
scientists now is the
sort of the great mystery
people are trying to solve.
It's been moving in the
Republican direction
for three decades, you can
just see it at each point.
Bill Clinton reversed it a
bit, Obama reversed it a bit
but it's really been headed that way.
Probably and certainly in the South
since the Civil Rights Act and
in the rest of the country
since the Reagan era.
Reagan Democrats, those
were working class whites.
It's a huge part of the electorate.
I think some progressives
think it's kind of
gonna disappear, they're gonna die off
by suicide or opioid
overdose or just old age.
They're 40% of the electorate
from what I understand so
it's kind of like staring you in the face.
It's something even if you don't like
its political behavior
you can't wish it away.
- Your analysis and description,
your descriptive analysis
looks at many factors in
explaining where we are.
But you've come under criticism from
your friend Ta-Nehisi Coates in a piece in
The Atlantic and I guess in his new book
as both ignoring race and
then on the other hand
not seeing race as really
the cause of everything
that has come to pass with Trump.
So that Trump, he calls him the first
white president and
that Obama's presidency
made Trump inevitable I think he said.
- Yeah and I think the first
white president is a brilliant
insight and I think it I agree with that.
Yeah I don't want to
put words in his mouth
but he criticized that
piece that you mentioned,
my piece pre-election for focusing
so much attention on the
white working class and
why it had left the Democratic Party
and gone to the Republicans
and why it seemed to
have been captured by
Trump and Coates thought
you're just trying to in
some way separate yourself
and all whites from
this class when in fact
Trump got the support,
the majority of votes
from every category of whites
including educated whites.
And so he really is the white president
who represents the return of,
after eight years of Obama
kind of a vengeful return
of white supremacy to
our to our politics and
he thought I was evading that and maybe
evading my own complicity in that.
And you know it's hard
to answer a charge of
you're just avoiding
the truth about yourself
when that truth is a truth that I,
it's sort of I was born with that truth.
My answer is no one should
ever underestimate race
in America and certainly Trump brought it
to a new level of explicit
and broadly accepted vitriol.
Although he was much more concerned
with immigrants and Muslims
during his campaign rallies
than he was with black Americans.
The focus was more on
those other groups so
to put it in black and white
terms I think is a bit of
a misread of where Trump, what
particular kinds of hostility
and bigotry he was stirring up.
But certainly it also had to do with
our ancient racial burden
and yet then you start
thinking about the other things
that got Trump where he was.
How can we ignore the
fact that Hillary Clinton
was the first woman to come
that close to the presidency
and that the hatred for her was so intense
that it could not be explained
by her Email server alone?
It had to be on a more
primal level and I think
it had a lot to do with
her being a powerful woman.
So I think misogyny was
right there in the mix.
How can you ignore the
fact that the areas where
cultural resentment, racial
resentment was strongest
by polling numbers are
the same areas where
the sense of being under siege
by forces of globalization
and having the sort of the
underpinnings of your community
disappearing under your
feet and your children
struggling and your neighbors turning to
either drugs or crime or
government benefits or all of them,
how can you ignore that connection?
They are obviously related.
I don't want to have to
sort it all out and say
well it was 27% economics
and 43% race and 30%,
to me they reinforce each
other and I don't think of
race in our politics as
a fixed immutable force.
It can change depending on the
circumstances and context and
depending on the the
verbal atmosphere were in.
Trump unleashed things that
were obviously there but that
in other context would
keep themselves in check.
And he exacerbated them and amplified them
in ways that I don't
think any other politician
except maybe George Wallace
has done so explicitly
at that level, national level.
So I don't know it's a long way of saying
I think it's too complicated for one cause
to explain everything about Trump.
- One of the interesting parts
of your New Yorker article
was the evolution of the Democratic Party
because you're saying
that part of this story
and a very important part
is the Democratic Party's
changing of its primary constituency
from the working class to the meritocracy.
Talk a little about that
because that's critical here
because there there's so
many pieces to this puzzle.
And this is a truly important one.
- I tried to tell a
very simplified version
of the story of how beginning in
the late 60's really you can pinpoint it.
The '68 Democratic
convention which was a riot
forced changes in the party
that diminished the power
of the old brokers who
were the big city mayors,
the union leaders, kind of the New Deal
Democratic coalition and
forced the party to democratize
its selection process for president
and its selection process
for delegates so that
minority groups struggling
for equal rights,
single cause activists who were either
anti-war, pro-environment, et cetera,
what became known as the new politics,
younger, better educated, not attached
to these old institutions like unions.
That first emerged as a force in '72.
It helped get George McGovern nominated.
Bill Clinton was a
McGovern worker in Texas
with his girlfriend from
Yale Law School Hillary and
they were classic cases
of young boomers who
came out of, especially Bill Clinton,
out of an atmosphere that was more like
the New Deal Coalition but were headed
in a different direction
which was the direction of
it's sort of politics tinged with idealism
but also without much feel
for the issue of class and of
economic injustice and of kind
of the haves and have nots.
That's not the way Bill
Clinton I think saw politics.
And Gary Hart was a campaign
manager for George McGovern.
And Hart was the first one to really
take this new politics to the
presidential level in '84.
Bill Clinton was the first
to become president with it.
By the 90's the Democrats although they
still talked the talk of unions and of
economic justice we're really the party
of the educated, and of minorities.
Bill Clinton embrace
globalization with both arms.
He saw it as the answer.
He gave a speech at a White House
conference on the new economy.
Remember the new economy?
Everything was gonna be solved by,
we've repealed the business cycle.
It's just growth growth growth
because we have deregulation
plus technology, plus education,
plus breaking down
barriers between countries.
It is gonna be nonstop growth.
And he said that the internet would be
the greatest engine for reducing poverty
the world had ever seen,
which today looks mad.
That was the atmosphere around so that
style of Democrat took
over the party in the 90's
and Barack Obama I would
say is a creature of that
who came out of the same meritocratic
race that Bill Clinton
did so what that meant was
the connection to working class Americans
who were no longer organized
in unions so much and who were
turning to a more resentful
politics because of
a sense that they were being left behind.
Democrats really no longer
had that connection.
They talked it but they didn't have it.
But we didn't quite see it starkly
until 2016 when it decided the election.
- And what this transcension, sorry sir
transition leads to is
a lack of realization
when we come to Hillary's campaign
that you could have many policies,
proposed many policies that address
the problems we're
confronting but in a way
people weren't listening,
weren't interested
even when a policy was
passed they didn't realize
that they were benefiting from it.
And what replaced policy was identity.
- I got to interview her
a month before the election last year.
At that moment it seemed like
she was headed for victory.
I was asking her a bunch of questions
that were all around the
the fundamental question
how did the Democrats lose these voters?
Why are they all for your opponent,
and how can you get them back,
and how can you help them?
And she had a lot of answers.
She talked about corporate
responsibility and
profit sharing and getting
corporate corporations
to think more in the long
term and more about jobs
and less about the quarterly earnings.
She talked about breaking up monopolies.
She talked about getting
back to manufacturing
in parts of the country
where it had disappeared
and how you could do that.
She talked about, she used the
phrase educational elitism.
She was almost criticizing I think her own
husband and herself for having
moved the Democratic Party
or being part of a move
that really saw education
as the answer to everything.
She understood that that
left out a lot of people
who were never going to
get a graduate degree
and never going to be symbolic
analysts in the new economy.
She was thinking about that but there were
all these small bore policy ideas.
And I thought while I was listening to her
these all sound good.
I really have barely heard
any of this on the campaign.
I'm sure you've said it but it just didn't
get through 'cause the noise is too loud.
And it's not gonna help
you on election day.
It's not gonna get the voters who are
the objects of these ideas to vote for you
because that's not why they
are voting the way they vote.
- And interestingly as you look at this
embrace of globalization, the abandonment
of the working class,
the emphasis on diversity
and responding to
individual constituencies
and their right to realize their identity
that on the one hand Trump
then becomes a response
in a weird kind of way
to what the forces that
the Democratic Party was
unintentionally setting in place.
So as you focus on discreet identities
it opens up the identification of
the working class with
the white working class.
- Yeah exactly because although
my conversation with
Hillary Clinton was about
the working class and jobs and policies
her campaign was an
identity politics campaign
in the sense that she was really speaking
to a lot of different
identity groups and saying
I've got your back I've got
your back and hoping that
the some of them all including
her own identity group
educated professionals,
would be enough to get her over the top.
Rather than a truly compelling
vision that rose above them.
I mean she said stronger
together that was her slogan
but it felt like an empty slogan.
What Republicans used to do
in response to that is to say
we Republicans stand for a
transcendent American vision.
We're not gonna divide
you up into these groups
which of course they were doing because
they were locking out groups
from their share of the pie.
But they were speaking to a
kind of universal identity.
That's not what Trump did.
Trump didn't talk the Reagan
talk of the city on the hill.
Trump made it clear that
he was there for you,
white, Christian, largely small town
rural Heartland Americans.
They became a big identity
group among others
and they became the focus of Trump.
Remember I love the poorly educated.
That's 'cause they were
his biggest supporters and
he didn't say the white poorly educated
but everyone understood
what he was saying.
Trump beat Hillary by creating
a bigger identity group
than the ones that supported Hillary.
- The election, and now
if you watch the news you,
and I should say again
that in a way your book
helped us understand the context
that was pushing all of this along.
But what has a sense that
the country is breaking apart
basically or at a minimum
there are two worlds
that don't talk to each other
and have their own media.
Yesterday in your lecture you identified
four different narratives
of the way people
are telling their story
and trying to retell
the story of America and point
to the future for America.
Briefly recount the four
groups narratives that you see.
- And you could easily
come up with others.
These are the four that I
think are the strongest.
And they're sort of...
Something I saw in my reporting
for the unwinding was that
although the left right
division is very real and deep,
it's a giant Marianas Trench
across which no one can travel.
And the two sides are in these mutually
incomprehensible hostile
camps, that is all true.
If you watch Fox News all day
long you will be saturated
with a worldview that
is impenetrable to me.
And you will not have,
be able to listen to me
and I won't be able to listen
to you and that's where we are
and social media, Twitter and Facebook,
have utterly intensified that and made it
sort of tailored to the person.
But in addition to left right,
red blue we have up and down.
So if there are these the
four narratives that I
talked about they are
up and down narratives.
The up narrative on the
right is libertarian America
which is the Koch brothers narrative.
The up narrative on the left
is cosmopolitan America.
It's the narrative of globalization and
tolerance and openness and
the flow of people and goods
and information which
is the Clintons America.
The down narrative on the right
is America first, its Trump.
And the down narrative on
the left is diverse America.
It's groups that have been
historically oppressed
that are now saying we
demand our share and
in the lecture I
discussed how I think that
just a necessary goal, can
easily become an end in it.
That the identity as a category
for getting equal rights
becomes an end in itself
and almost becomes
a form of separatism which
is where diverse America
our identity politics is going,
especially in cultural
institutions like universities
and like media, foundations,
even elementary schools.
I see it in my own kids education so.
None of those groups speaks
to the whole country,
all of them have winners
and losers in their story.
And they are all entrenched in a sort of a
zero sum battle for power
that may be inevitable.
Politics is a struggle for power but
they don't speak to us as citizens.
And they don't find a way
of being truly inclusive
So I think that's, it's
just a way of looking
at how truly tribal our
politics have become.
Where we cannot understand each other,
we see each other as
illegitimate in some ways.
To even speak to someone
from a different tribe
is to give them a legitimacy
they don't deserve.
And each tribe hopes and thinks
the other will somehow disappear
either by being beaten in the polls
or by dying off, by being walled off.
It's as if they can't acknowledge that
the country is made up of
more than their own tribe.
- What sort of leadership,
what sort of ideas
should we be looking for
to take us over these humps
because really your
description is so powerful
of what's going on that it
almost seems impossible to
bring us together again to use
a hackneyed phrase from the past.
Is it this idea that you
talked about yesterday
of citizenship, and civic education,
and maybe at the local level
and not in national leadership?
- I think local politics is
much more hopeful because
it's just not as poisoned
as national politics.
It's not as paralyzed and
dysfunctional as Congress.
People have to look at each
other and deal with each other.
They're talking about
issues that they have
in common like the air they breathe.
It's kind of hard to...
Yes we can politicize
the air we breathe but
in the end you better have a solution
or you're not gonna get reelected.
You know citizenship is both to me
the most inclusive category
and also a kind of empty
category in that it doesn't
have a political content.
It doesn't have ideas.
It's more of a kind of an activity.
But it's an activity that we've lost.
It may be coming back
I mean there's a lot of
stirrings of civic activism
both on the right and the left.
The Tea Party was a big one on the right.
It was kind of nihilistic
and it burned itself out.
The reaction to Trump is
now showing lots of life
and showing you know a
citizenry that actually
is quite alert and awake and wants to
get involved in public life.
There's a lot of
candidates for local office
on the Democratic side that
would not have shown up
two years ago or four years ago.
But meanwhile the Democratic
Party lost 1000 offices
during the Obama years and
became a hollow structure
without any real organic connection
to their own base and their own voters so
that's part of this institutional collapse
that I was talking about in my book.
I don't think a single
leader's gonna do it.
These are deep fundamental
disagreements of value.
There's no real papering them
over with inspiring rhetoric.
I do think Barack Obama tried.
This was what his presidency was about.
It was about uniting us.
And in the last year of his presidency
he gave a series of speeches
that never got much attention
'cause the campaign was
so loud but that were
like a last farewell testament
of what democracy is about.
So it's worth looking at those speeches
'cause he talks about empathy,
about listening to people
who are not like you
who you disagree with.
You may not ever agree with them
but you have to listen to them.
He talks about reason and about facts and
about the long term and things
not happening overnight.
Lots of to me you know
kind of the garden variety
democratic values and he
was trying to reaffirm
them when he had a chance
before he had to say goodbye and
right now it looks, yeah
those things seem weak
and almost namby-pamby compared to
what we're up against with
the current president but
we shouldn't lose sight of
them 'cause without them
and especially that ability to actually...
It's a very painful thing
to get outside yourself
and listen to someone who you deeply
disagree with and maybe deeply dislike.
But right now it's almost considered
immoral to do that on
both sides on all sides.
Evangelical Christians
may think it's immoral
to even listen to
someone who's pro choice.
But it's a perilous thing
to stop that because
a democracy needs citizens above all.
- Obama was articulating in a
way a philosophical statement.
There is the problem
which you've identified
and others have identified
that when you do something
good for people, good in the sense
of addressing their problems
they don't realize it.
It doesn't enter their
consciousness in terms of
changing their identity and
partly this is the result
of a lack of political education.
It's also of what technology
has done to the media
and to the way things are reported.
And you've written a lot on on the sort of
negative impacts of technology.
- Yeah I mean I'm a bit of
a technophobe I suppose.
I had a visceral feeling that when I first
got to know Twitter that
this was not going to
empower all of us to be
more active citizens.
It was gonna become an
addiction and probably
eventually a fairly destructive addiction.
And right now Twitter seems to me like
a pretty negative force in
our politics and Facebook too.
I didn't see the ways in which ideologues
and Russians were going
to use them to try to
create divisions or exacerbate divisions.
But that's a an incredible
new thing in our politics
that the Russians understood first.
They were already there
and they looked at us
and at Poland and Hungary and
France and Catalonia and said
we know how to to really
turn you against each other
to make the very idea
that there might be truth
kind of in doubt, just
destabilize everything.
It's not gonna build anything new.
It's just totally destructive
but we know how to do it.
And Facebook and Twitter
turned out to be ideal
platforms for that kind
of nihilistic activity.
And we Americans turned out
to be perfect marks for it.
And man those those fake
news stories were genius.
They were targeted at
particular communities.
They were sort of in this devilish way
of how could I really freak
out some white Christians
in small towns outside Detroit?
Well maybe if I create a fake group
that is militantly anti-Islamophobia
they might think they're
coming, they're taking over.
It worked.
It wouldn't have worked if our democracy
had not been so fragile but
we had reached the point
where we were kind of prey to this and
I don't know how you undo that.
- It's interesting that
the intelligence services
didn't identify this problem
until it was too late
in the game as far as the
election was concerned.
- And unfortunately the
Obama administration
did identify it and didn't
do anything about it
until it was too late because in his
fair minded and above it all way he didn't
want to seem to be taking sides.
Of course he endorsed
a campaign for Hillary
but he didn't want to
be using intelligence
and the National Security
Council to indict
her opponent Donald Trump
for colluding with Russians.
And yet they knew he
was so hat's on Obama.
I bet Hillary will never
forgive him for that.
- One final question.
Your descriptive analysis in,
because of its objectivity,
and because of your perceptive eye and ear
for hearing what's going on
doesn't have a lot of hope for the reader.
It may appear to be more
pessimistic than you are.
What are the threads of hope that you see?
- I mean they're very
hard to find right now.
When I look at the
humiliation of America as a
force for good in the world,
as a leader in the eyes of our allies.
When I look at the disgraceful behavior
at the highest levels in our government.
When I look at corruption becoming
I mean it's like people
don't even have the bandwidth
to think about how much
corruption is happening
in a daily way between
the Trump organization
and the Trump administration
or the Kushner organization.
It's pretty hard to say
yeah well if only we
got rid of this guy because
I think it's much bigger
and deeper and more
long lasting than Trump.
It's about a weakening of
our faith in democracy and
Trump has exploited
that pretty brilliantly.
I think the only answer
is to try to combat it
in one's own life and in one's activities
and in what you do and support.
It's not gonna succeed overnight.
The Democrats may not take
back Congress next year.
They probably won't.
They can't lose heart because of that
because this is a long struggle.
And it's not just about
Democrats retaking Congress.
It's about solving
problems that will win back
the trust of voters
whose trust they've lost.
It's very hard to sustain
very much optimism.
I don't have a choice I have children.
I mean this is the country
that they're growing up in.
And I can't let them give up on it.
- Well on that note
George I want to thank you
for coming back on our program
and keep the books and articles coming.
- Thanks for having me.
- 'Cause that's a step toward our
understanding what's going on.
- That's my small contribution.
- Thank you very much.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(contemplative music)